it's the mix at GDC 2016 I'm here with
Thierry thanks for being here and you
are from gloomy wood studios and you're
gonna show me to dark today yeah sweet
so let's get right into it and give me a
little bit of an overview of this game
it's definitely exactly what you would
expect from the title it's a gloomy dark
game give me a little bit more of an
overview you won't lose that first
definitely okay this is story this was
my first free weekend in a while with my
family-owned engine I know it's on the
background with ties like old school
things but we use normal Maps without
those maps onyx and all the characters
are voxels
there are mega folks are but rendering
pixels deserves a look of the sprite but
as you can see it and we firstly and we
can take the light so this is a nice
family in the forest beginning of the
story know you so you made your own
engine for this and what was the
reasoning behind that gameplay in fact
um My partner made this game Ronan's
adults 25 years ago we began as a
survival thing mm-hmm
putting with the lights and so we wanted
a retro look and also thing you can play
with the lights so you can see that like
this way
sprites with things like only one thing
I know what's what's your goal here
obviously you're just trying to survive
there's a lot of bad things in these
woods
um just wait five minutes yeah sure
so I only think it's about children and
this all died strange but in space just
a bruise
this on since nights
okay since this time is searching for
children even in 17 years later maybe I
I won't just go back to the main menu
and go to a conclave on in fact every
level well is looking for is Suren
anyone mr. Alcala who kidnapped Shirin
so the goal of the game is who will to
release it ruin from our seventeen years
later
yeah alright so what are you gonna show
me now you're gonna show me a later
level a level one style killer is the
first level two it's a new one sing
children on me ditch so the goal is to
so it's a bit irrational or education
they are you have your goal
who's this disgusting I know but you
have to say we are six children so
you're trying to find them all now this
said it was also M in addition it's a
stealth game there's stealth aspects to
this yep completely so I took my stick
so yeah I ago this idea is that I can
get dirty saved one child yeah I said
she wanted to show you that no I said I
now three and I have to find all the
other one in the level now all these are
yours those you're like no no no you
just see no in fact there is a story at
least you won't for all level and level
met also sells kilos but at least you're
gonna find why there was so many celty
revealed now studio is just same names
and just sitting around so you know we
are a middle and now yeah tell me you
have a full inventory system was that
pack of cigarettes huh I have a pack of
cigarettes because if I want to save and
I think it could be a good idea now so
it if I want to save our
it's not so simple for me from speaking
sometimes and without a forget to say so
is your oh yeah so what's that what do
you worry you're gonna ban Manuel
animals is that right gonna hurt you Yas
but I know im sue Oh
Oh solo but now you're too dead
I'm to dead start again yeah to save
your game you have to do smoke you smoke
to save yeah but thing about well you
have to wait for few minutes smoking so
it could be dangerous in fact to save
that's I have to save fighting for the
non-smokers that you have a special go
to pass the level with optimal
incentives to risk it all to keep going
without saving oh and now what other
environments can we expect to see you
and you already have like a lot of
creepy stuff going on you're gonna be in
a like with like an abandoned creepy
amusement park for this one yeah this is
the first one let me get her lamp and my
again
and now is this coming out for Xbox and
PC and peaceful and ps4 and a help for a
far along in development are you Wow
Morris so DM I guess you're hoping to be
at the end here
oh well we'll do it easy shuffle shelf
and minuets
who's that guy trying to tell him that I
have nobody okay so what else can you do
for now I can try to pass this way but I
have to find a light
so to find some light somewhere system
is closed so I guess I have to find
another way to go what killed you I
guess a trap sorry I won't take another
simple one okay how long is the full
playthrough of the game I guess 20 hours
okay
are you have six bit level and in
between each level you have to go to
this place this place is a CERN
this is teaching you to use your
inventory system so this your place
yes this is your room so you can have
your lamp you can find you're getting
somewhere
yeah you're just trying to save kids
somewhere out there in fact yeah you
have a person well yep and with this
book I won't yeah in fact where the
television existed I show you to assist
evolve in a forest this is an
introduction and after you enter in the
room in this room and this is the
television news to tell you that's a
response from the village kids yeah so
you are going to the community so you're
pretty much investigating the
disappearance of these kids I'm trying
to say yep that's it and after I have my
secretly out somewhere yeah
so they can up open ways book well this
is your secret area it's like you're out
and yeah you have the room you agree
with map and I'm I just an those who
commute amusement park and you have also
level 2 and look yeah and it's aliens
from level to level
that's it and what inspired such a dark
story well I tell you it's first alone
in the dog we wanted to do another thing
and while sure you mean wife Shirin and
say look you know she ruins maybe fall
alone in the dog it was an idea we were
young and I was the biggest important
thing is your life is yourself and now
we are old as the biggest thing is our
children so we just think save it
generally means just more importance and
saving yourself
wrenching thing you can do is make them
lose their children in the first 30
seconds the game will think he's hearing
for showing me that that was too dark
and that will be coming to PC ps4 and
Xbox but do you have any kind of
timeframe in mind for when that will
happen don't yell end of the year No
alright sweet well thank you very much
and we have a lot more games coming up
so stay tuned and thank you guys for
watching
you